hey i'm eddie wu this is education live
we're talking about
maths in the everyday world and it's a
great delight for me to be here with my
friend
and fashion expert kelly hush kelly
thanks for joining us today hi eddie how
are you
i'm fantastic and just really glad that
we get the opportunity to speak with you
about how mathematics is part of the
work that you do every day
before we start talking about that um
where are we right now
we are in carla's and patty's design
studio and we have the machinists behind
us who are actually making a dress which
is going to the new collection
so spring summer 2020. fantastic so
they'll make the sample
and carla will approve it but before
that the pattern was being made by nam
in the background who's the head pattern
maker
but carla will try it on she still loves
to try everything on and then she'll
approve it and if she loves it then
we'll go into production and probably
eight to 12 weeks we'll see it in store
amazing it's great journey from idea
inception all the way to actually being
on store floors now um it's great to
understand what's happening here but i
want to know a bit more about
you kelly you've been in the industry
for
long enough now that you've got many
many different hats that you've worn
in the fashion space could you give us a
bit of a sense of your trajectory
through this one the different
roles you've taken on in there i started
my career in the media i always wanted
to be a journalist but
i worked out pretty quickly that i could
combine two passions which was fashion
and journalism so i
entered into fashion journalism and
ended up being editor-in-chief of
harper's bazaar which was
the best job in australia in publishing
and then i left there and
launched a retail business which was
exciting
very different to what i'd done for for
two decades but learnt a lot and i've
worked with carla as well on her
business so
i've been able to use that journalism
and that fashion career to go into other
things which has been great
it's amazing diversity 100 now speaking
of like the nuts and bolts of fashion
i'm looking at some of the designs over
here and like i'm trying to understand
from a mathematics standpoint like the
geometry here it's kind of
you know we've got these flat fabrics
and you know
we've got to wrap them around this
three-dimensional unusual
shape a human body and you know it's
even hard enough mathematicians talk
about trying to take
you know the world which is just a
simple round sphere
and how challenging it is to turn that
into a flat surface can you tell us a
bit about trying to do that in reverse
with a garment like this
i can show you well i think you know
this is the final garment so this is a
sample that is in the new collection but
basically it starts out like a piece of
paper which is the pattern
um and then that's the collar right
right so
this is how it fits on that's how it
fits on
so it could be a sense you cut the
fabric to that but i suppose this even
looks crazier
yeah where is that going to fit it's the
sleeve right so this is on the shoulder
yeah so that actually helps it yeah and
so that that but again because the arm
is not flat
has to wrap around i see yeah and i
think too it's important to say this is
like a size eight so this is we sample
in a size eight which is the smaller
size
it takes that's fabric but yeah it's the
smaller size we make so
and then obviously a pattern for a size
12 and a size 14 will be
scale up from there so there's a lot of
thinking about proportions and ratios
and measurement in that right
exactly and that's you know quite often
fashion studios like this will have a
fit model
as well so everything is is you know
fitted on the same
same body every time and karla has done
that for for a long time so
you know the size eight is his colors
figure yeah so if you look like colors
and patty then you're a perfect size
that would be very handy so i'd love to
know i mean you mentioned before
um you know going into media journalism
and the owning a business and what that
was like
i imagine there's a lot of mathematics
to actually make sure a business is
profitable can you talk me a bit about
the challenges you've met there and how
mathematics has helped you
mathematics said like you know i think
i've said this before i wasn't a great
student to
in when i started out at school but
maths is
every day in fashion and you don't
realize that when you first start out
you just think it's beautiful clothes
and talking to designers and in my case
i was a journalist i was all about the
words
but it's not true i mean everything that
you do in fashion is about mathematics
um it can be the store floor so you need
to know how many garments you need to
have on that floor
what you're going to sell through how to
be profitable to the pattern making
because that's all measurement obviously
and you have to get it precise if you
don't get it precise and then your
garment comes in it may not fit
so then you have a whole collection of
garments that don't fit properly and i
know designers that have done that where
a whole collection has been terrible
because the fit's not right so
everything that you look at there is
some element of mathematics in it
and just coming back to something you
said before you know when you mentioned
like a store floor sort of something
intriguing in my brain
just thinking about its area obviously
the bigger your store is
the more you have to pay in rent and
other costs and then i'm thinking about
you know your staff and then i assume a
lot of the materials might come from
overseas how do you factor all of that
into working out profit and loss and all
the rest
you need a very big spreadsheet we talk
a lot about in fashion about landing
costs so a garment
so something like this it's like okay
how much did the fabric cost
how much do the buttons cost how much
does the lining cost how much does it
cost a warehouse how much does it cost
to get it into store
how much does your staff cost and you
have to put all of that into a budget
and then work out
what do you have to sell this jacket for
so that it's profitable
so it's yeah i mean you might look at
this and go okay it's a thousand dollar
jacket but
where does that thousand dollars come
from and if you sell something
to just cover your material costs you're
going to go broke and
that's the reality and that's why
opening a store is so difficult because
every square metre is worth money and
you've got to put that
even with staff if you have a really big
store you've got to have a lot of staff
and that eats into your profit as well
absolutely so all they're all part of
the overheads that are part of your
bottom line
so i'm really interested you know when
we think about um someone you know who's
who's at home and they're thinking i do
maths
i answer some questions i i try and get
the right answer
you're talking about having this
enormous spreadsheet and there is no
right answer some way that oh this is
correct what's what's the process been
like for you as a business owner to try
and say okay
i'm trying to solve a problem i've got
you know this season that's coming up i
want to make sure that i i make
this amount of profit and i stay afloat
how how do you what's the thought
process behind
you know trying to get you know a
decision about how much stock you're
going to have or
how many lines you're going to have this
season how does that work in your brain
oh it's difficult and i think being
conservative i think you need to be a
little bit conservative when you're
starting out because obviously you'd
like to put everything
into the store as well like you want
everything you want you know your
customer to be able to buy
anything they want but the reality is
again is you can't do that so quite
often a designer will
start out and there'll be 50 designs in
the collection but once you start
looking at what really is going to make
sense so you know profit wise or what
you can sell through or how much the
fabric is going to cost and that kind of
makes you decide what goes into that
collection what's going to go into store
but there is a lot of back and forth and
i think there's a lot of learnings along
the way so i think when you do start a
business you have to be very
conservative
to start with and probably and do your
research as well you need to look at
what your competitors are doing
so if they've got 10 pairs of jeans in
their collection and
15 jackets then you should probably be
thinking about 15 pairs of jeans and 10
jackets and not doing
30 pairs of jeans and two jackets
because i think you need to have a look
at what other businesses are doing to be
successful as well
that's amazing because you mentioned
before we can often have a fairly
romantic view
of you know particularly going into such
a creative pursuit um but you've really
got to be able to marry both of those
together and i guess a lot of successful
businesses in fashion kind of have that
as a
you know they've got someone who can
crunch those numbers and understand that
right
yes you need a very good financial
manager when you're a creative person
and if you
know there's nothing wrong with being
totally creative right and if that's
that's your thing
but you need to have someone in the
business who has a business mind
because the reality is is you need to be
a good business person to have a
successful business person and a lot of
fashion businesses run from season to
season
so you will sell through your collection
from spring summer and then that will
fund your autumn winter collection
so spring summer doesn't work autumn
winter's going to be a disaster
so i think the really successful
businesses like you know
assassin bide and the zimmermann brands
which are really successful australian
businesses i mean colors and paddy
has a business mind and a creative mind
she's one of those rare
rare people one incredible thing to have
them both in the same mind but a lot of
businesses have that that finance brain
and that creative brain and it's the
perfect fit which i think also sort of
emphasizes
that um that creativity and technical uh
knowledge and expertise
really has to have collaboration in it
as well right that's so many of us it's
pretty unusual to be like carla and have
that all in one so we've got to be able
to work together
with people who have that skill right
yeah and you have to be able to listen
because if your finance manager
is saying if you make that dress in
the most expensive silk you can find in
italy and you sell it for two and a half
thousand dollars when most of your
dresses are only costing five hundred
dollars
you can't you can't do it and you're
like well i want to do it
i'm telling you now it's not going to
sell and then you do it
probably won't sell and then you've got
all those dresses for two and a half
thousand dollars
what do you do with a bit of financial
disaster it is it is and that's why
sometimes you need someone to say no the
commercial reality
of doing that doesn't make sense for the
business you know it's about survival
fashion is very much
you know it's a tough business so you do
have to be financially savvy
absolutely and i'm thinking about you
know everyone back home who is trying to
think about how they're doing maths and
you know i just want to get the right
answer
and then move on with it so i got a tick
that's enough but actually what you're
saying it seems to me is you're going to
be able to communicate that as well
right now i just want to come back to
you said you know media journalism is
what you wanted to launch into
what's it like running a magazine being
the editor-in-chief for something like
harper's bazaar which like you said
amazing job what kind of skills did you
use in that role
i needed to be a business manager it's a
creative job that you also need to be
financially savvy
i mean people look at a magazine and i
think oh beautiful pictures lots of
photography
amazing models great journalism but the
reality is is
that i have a budget for every single
magazine you know for a big issue it may
have been sixty thousand dollars for a
smaller issue it may have been
25 000 and within that i have 100 pages
or i have 200 pages so there is a dollar
value put against everything
so we have these amazing meetings where
we have these crazy creative ideas
and then it goes into the budgeting
stage it's like okay well we can't
really shoot that in the bahamas because
basically the flights there for the
crews
crew are going to kill our entire budget
so it is that we have that
you know you have that beautiful ability
to come up with crazy ideas
and and then it sometimes most of the
time gets narrowed down because of
budget restraints
no it's amazing i mean i think about
yeah you know opening up
a beautiful spread and thinking you know
every single page
the numbers have been crushed in the
background to make sure that every
single one plays its role
i'm sure whoever was designing that
particular screen would have loved for
twice as many pages
but there's a reality there and when you
think about marketing advertising all
the rest
yeah but you know i used to be a little
bit cheeky so i'd spend a lot of money
one month knowing i could save it later
along so then my finance
finance manager would be like what have
you done i'd be like don't worry i'll
save it at the back end of the year
i've got a plan yeah i've got a plan
that december issue there's gonna be no
money i'll just be really creative
i might be on the cover so that's well
i suppose when you have a face like
yours kelly i guess not everyone has the
privilege of being able to do that
i wouldn't do that to my team now i'm
kind of thinking about everyone who's
viewing and
who you know perhaps would love a career
in the fashion industry
and you've come through you know like
you said not
enjoying mathematics particularly when
you were at school do you have any
advice that you could pass on to
everyone who's watching along about
what their attitude to mathematics
should be if they're heading into
something like fashion or other creative
industries
stick with it i think you also don't
have to be in the a
you know the a class that's really
important i think you really need to
stick with it because
i think i was in year 11 i was like i
don't need it you know i'm great at
english i'm really good at drama
you know i was getting a's in everything
i did other than maths and
it was like i'm gonna get rid of that so
that my report card looks perfect
but the reality is is i needed maths and
as soon as i got into the workforce
it was like i just wish i'd stuck with
it and probably took the pressure off
myself and dropped down a class where it
was a little bit easier
for me and i think that's really
important it's maths is so
important and it didn't matter how many
times my english my
my math teacher said there you go that's
a mental block my math teacher said to
me just stick with it you'll need
it even you know a home loan and things
like that you'll need it and i'm like oh
i'll be fine
but you do need it there is maths maths
in every day and everything that you do
even in a creative space you need to be
good at least have some knowledge of
math you don't have to be brilliant but
you need it
that's such an important message that
mathematics sounds like it's an
essential tool
to every day um kelly thank you so much
for your time it's been a pleasure
and um thanks for everyone tuning in
have a good one guys